[Música]
hay una crisis de gobierno en Colombia
el presidente Gustavo Petro y dos de los
que eran sus funcionarios más cercanos
han estado envueltos en escándalos
relacionados con la financiación de su
campaña con interceptaciones telefónicas
entre otros todo comenzó cuando la
niñera de la jefa de gabinete de Laura
Sarabia denunció que la acusaban de
robar varios millones de pesos de la
casa de Sarabia y que por eso la
llevaron al polígrafo cerca de la casa a
presidencial luego la revista cambió
reveló que el teléfono de la niñera
marelvis Meza habría sido interceptado
ilegalmente el ahora ex embajador en
Caracas Armando Benedetti se involucró
al ser quien recomendó a Sarabia y con
quien en los últimos días tenía más
discordias que puntos en común él tenía
un descontento pues no quería estar más
en Venezuela y aspiraba a un alto cargo
En el gobierno después de la revista
semana publicó casi media hora de audios
de Benedetti hablando supuestamente de
con Sarabia en uno de ellos afirmó que
él como eje fundamental de la campaña
presidencial de Petro consiguió 15 mil
millones de pesos en financiación esto
es alrededor de 3,5 millones de dólares
y agregó que si habla sobre quién los
financió todos se van a la cárcel además
Benedetti y Sarabia Fueron destituidos
por el presidente Petro escuchemos
palabras de Benedetti
[Música]
fueron los hoteles
en serio Me siento peor que el viernes
pasado
luego de que se conociera este y los
demás audios el presidente Pedro publicó
un tuit en el que niega haber recibido
ese dinero y califica las afirmaciones
de su ex embajador como un chantaje
Petro dice además que se trata de un
golpe blando contra su gobierno
yo no acepto chantajes ni veo a la
política como un espacio de favores
personales aquí estoy solo para lograr
más justicia social en mi país es eso lo
que me mueve y obsesiona si hay personas
en otra lógica diferente en el gobierno
es mejor que se separen de él al día
siguiente de este tuit el ex embajador
Benedetti reconoció que quería un
espacio político en el gobierno y
también dijo que estaba bajo los efectos
del alcohol sin precisar cuánto
he sido parte fundamental del actual
proyecto político del presidente Petro
sin embargo no satisfecho con lo que me
correspondió políticamente en un acto de
debilidad y tristeza me dejé llevar por
la rabia y El trago
El caso es que desde la oposición ya
comenzaron las denuncias esto tras los
comentarios implícitos de que habría
dineros sucios en la campaña
presidencial de Petro el primer gobierno
de izquierda en Colombia al mandatario
lo denunciaron ante la comisión de
acusaciones de la cámara de
representantes la única con poder para
juzgar a un presidente uno de los
denunciantes es Federico Gutiérrez
posible candidato para las elecciones
locales del próximo octubre
vengo a erradicar esta denuncia basada
en los últimos hechos de las últimas
horas y los últimos días donde se
evidencia
irregularidad en financiación de la
campaña la presidenta de la presidencia
de parte de la campaña del señor Gustavo
Petro con las últimas declaraciones es
que estamos también es frente a un
gobierno ilegal yo le pido al presidente
Petro
que asuma la responsabilidad y renuncia
hay una intención de la derecha por
tumbar al presidente Gustavo Petro en
Colombia como dicen los progobierno o es
una implosión dentro del mismo gabinete
Qué pasará ahora con el primer
mandatario de izquierda para analizar el
tema hoy nos acompaña de nuestro estudio
Hernán cadavid representante a la cámara
por el partido de oposición centro
democrático y desde Bogotá se conecta
Alfredo Mondragón representante por el
pacto histórico el partido oficialista a
ellos les doy la bienvenida y a ustedes
nuestra audiencia les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram estamos como arroba
franz24-raya al piso
esperaremos todos sus comentarios con el
numeral el debate f24 a mí me encuentran
como arroba maríaclaguirre no olviden
además que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar entonces dándole la
bienvenida al representante cadavid
Gracias por estar con nosotros vamos a
comenzar con lo general qué ve usted de
todos los escándalos que ha ocurrido en
los últimos días en Colombia bueno
Muchas gracias por invitarme a conversar
de estos hechos tan delicados para el
país y evidentemente hay es una
secuencia de hechos graves que se van
juntando uno tras otro no son carácter
aislado eso lo primero lo segundo Es que
esto profundiza un sentimiento de
incertidumbre que existía allá en el
país estos elementos profundizan Esa
condición no solamente en materia
política sino también en materia de
inversión por supuesto en estabilidad
jurídica y en mensaje internacional
una inversión tendría hoy muchas
restricciones o un inversionista tendría
hoy muchas razones para considerar
digamos llegar a Colombia y eso nos
preocupa bastante porque al final del
día esta situación política se termina
viendo reflejada es en la condición
social del país en materia de empleo en
en materia de estabilidad nos preocupa
demasiado ustedes menciona dos puntos
incertidumbre y un mal mensaje
internacional Alfredo Mondragón Gracias
por acompañarnos cuéntenos Usted qué
opina de manera general sobre estos
escándalos
Bueno mira creo que hay todo un interés
de los sectores tradicionales en el
poder que no soportan todavía no
soportan que haya llegado una fuerza
distinta y obviamente van a aprovechar
cualquier tipo de situación que ponga en
entredicho al gobierno la preocupación
principal que hay hoy del
establecimiento y de los sectores
tradicionales es que Petro en los pocos
meses Dentro de pocos meses le tocan que
presentar una terna para definir el que
quien va a suceder al fiscal Barbosa
actualmente fiscal Barbosa hoy
básicamente es el principal opositor
político del presidente Petro es una
persona que ha venido siendo muy
negligente la investigación es que
tienen que ver con los sectores
poderosos en Colombia y ha tenido una
postura más de hostigamiento contra el
gobierno y contra la reformas de tal
manera que estos sectores poderosos que
todavía no que se resisten aquí ya no
están en el poder ejecutivo pues
temerosos de que Petro defina una terna
con personas que estén por la verdad que
investiguen realmente las situaciones de
tantas masacres falsos positivos que han
habido en Colombia por toda la violencia
que ha padecido y buscan la manera de
que estos episodios le generen un
ambiente de tensión para que petroceda a
esas pretensiones Es decir para que
Petro no asuma un papel decidido en
Establecer un cambio de condición en la
institucionalidad en ese sentido lo que
se ha planteado es que lo que primero
comenzó como el gran escándalo de un
polígrafo a una mujer que cumpliera
funciones domésticas pasó después de que
el gobierno era el responsable de esa
interceptaciones se después se demuestra
que es un vínculo entre la fiscalía y un
funcionario de la dijin y ahora cuando
salen unos audios de Benedetti una
persona que lo ponen como si fuera el
arquitecto de la campaña de Petro cuando
se desconoce que el arquitecto de la
campaña del Petro fueron miles de
personas que de manera voluntarias
salieron a concitar el voto popular
Entonces ahora ponen a Benedetti como la
gran prueba pero el mismo Benedetti dice
que semana ha manipulado sus audios y
cuando eso sucede Petro le dice vaya
Benedetti lo que usted está diciendo de
que entraron unos recursos a la campaña
dígalo a la fiscalía Entonces ahora hay
toda una confusión y hay toda una
especie de de novela que lo que está
diciendo Petro es no me voy a dejar
chantajear vayan incluso donde mi mayor
opositor que el fiscal digan la verdad
bajo gravedad de juramento y que no haya
más mentiras que haya es verdad en
Colombia creo que esa es la gran
preocupación que hay en este momento en
Colombia sí sus puntos Entonces es un
ambiente de atención provocado por un
sector que quiere ir en contra del
presidente y usted menciona varios
puntos sin embargo vamos a discutir esto
de manera cronológica para poder
desglosar bien este tema que para una
audiencia internacional como la es muy
complejo para cualquiera de nosotros
incluso es complejo de comprender
Comencemos precisamente con lo que usted
menciona representante de Mondragón y
son las interceptaciones presuntamente
ilegales del teléfono de marelvis Meza
la niñera de la jefa de gabinete Laura
Sarabia y la llevada al polígrafo le
quiero comenzar a preguntar a usted
Hernán al respecto Cómo entender esto y
simplemente para explicarle a nuestra
audiencia como un caso de una niñera
termina convirtiéndose en un caso que
involucra a los miembros del gobierno
Bueno lo primero y muy importante para
decirle a la opinión es que estos hechos
no nacen de una denuncia de la oposición
o de un tercero o de una estructuración
de información externa nacen
precisamente del corazón de la casa de
nariño y están vinculados a la persona
más cercana al presidente de la
república la que comparte con el mañana
tarde y noche que comparte con él en el
avión en la oficina o en el vehículo
Entonces se cae esa narrativa que esto
es una articulación de sectores que
quieren derrumbar un modelo de cambio no
yo creo que esa narrativa ya está
agotada porque los hechos se producen
precisamente desde la propia casa de
nariño que es el palacio de gobierno en
Colombia lo segundo aquí nos dejan todas
las preocupaciones que el director de la
Policía Nacional y el ministro de la
defensa una vez se conoció el hecho de
las llamadas chuzadas o interceptación
ilegal al teléfono lo que salieron fue
dar un discurso de revestimiento de
legalidad cuando ellos no son los
autorizados ni tienen la condición para
hacerlo solo determinarán las
autoridades tercero quisieron hacer ver
que era legal que ese procedimiento si
hubiese llevado a cabo no existe
reglamento no existe Norma que permita a
una persona funcionaria pública hacerle
un procedimiento de polígrafo aún con su
consentimiento siendo un particular eso
está reservado para autoridad judicial
de ahí parten los hechos que van digamos
decantándose en lo que ya tenemos y es
una propia grabación hecha por la señora
Laura Sarabia asistente del presidente
Armando Benedetti esto no fue que lo
presentó la oposición
dos puntos aquí importantes uno hay una
discusión en el país en Colombia sobre
quién interceptó o Quién dio la orden de
interceptar los teléfonos de la niñera
marelvis Meza y de otra de las niñeras
que trabajaba con Sarabia si esto vino
desde la policía o si vino desde la
fiscalía Le quiero preguntar a Alfredo
Usted qué opina sobre este caso puntual
de las interceptaciones y que
responderle al representante de cadavid
que dice que este escándalo no nace de
adentro y no se trata de una
articulación de sectores contra Petro
mira cada vez que y la primera reacción
del presidente Petro Y es que haya
verdad y se investigue pues empiezan a
aparecer las llaves como se dice Y es
que siempre se le ha querido acusar o
prejuzgar al gobierno que ha sido una
autorización de parte del gobierno
solicitar interceptaciones o obligar a
hacer pruebas de polígrafo pero lo que
resulta según el abogado Miguel Ángel
del río un abogado que ASUME la
protección o el caso de funcionarios
técnicos que le corresponde hacer las
interceptaciones y ellos estos
funcionarios técnicos le dicen a Miguel
Ángel del río que ellos estaban haciendo
una investigación a un grupo criminal
criminal en Colombia que se llama el
clan del Golfo que ya habían tenido por
unos informantes Pues precisamente datos
importantes sobre cierta investigaciones
y que esos informantes le dieron unos
números telefónicos para ser interceptar
que entonces el técnico de
de interceptaciones
le solicita como es debido a la fiscalía
que autorice esas interceptaciones las
autorizan y cuando hace la
interceptaciones se dan cuenta que esos
números esa escucha no tenían que ver
con el proceso del Clan del Golfo pero
la fiscalía duró siete días seguiré con
las escuchas sin interrumpirlas de tal
manera de que rápidamente se dan cuenta
de que esto no es de un interés del
gobierno sino que la fiscalía permanece
manteniendo la interceptación sin que
hoy respondan Cuál es la situación sin
embargo el fiscal se ha adelantado a
dejar expuesto a este funcionario
técnico ya y empieza ahora entonces
cuando se supera ese debate ahora
empieza es otra discusión no les pasó lo
del polígrafo no les cuajó lo del tema
de las interceptaciones y ahorita
entonces lo que buscan es señalar que es
el debate las declaraciones de Armando
lo que muestra la gran preocupación o la
crisis del gobierno y lo que ha dicho
nuevamente el gobierno el presidente
Petro Qué es señor Benedetti según sus
declaraciones vaya donde el fiscal y
rinda las declaraciones porque el fiscal
bajo la gravedad de juramento del que
tiene que conocer sus declaraciones y lo
que yo digo es si el gobierno estuviera
tapando algo por qué lo manda su
principal compositor político y que el
fiscal Por supuesto que lo que está
buscando el presidente Petro es la
verdad por lo tanto creemos que es una
manipulación bastante grande de estos
digamos eh sucesos que están dando
hermanos no Simplemente decir que el
gobierno nacional Si tuviera toda la
apertura su actitud Debería ser la de
permitir la investigación con
tranquilidad y no una agresión entre los
poderes si hay una duda que se
esclarezca y que se permitan pero no una
agresión a las instituciones permanentes
eso es motivo de Gran preocupación
nuestra lo segundo lo que dice el
representante muy rápidamente No es que
no haya cuajado es que los hechos son
recientes apenas están empezando los
actos de investigación tanto de la
procuraduría en materia disciplinaria
como de la fiscalía en materia penal
Esto no se resuelve en ocho días y
tendrá además mucho fondo e insisto esto
no nace ni llega desde sectores terceros
u opositores sino voz y actuaciones
propias de las personas del corazón del
gobierno de Colombia y como usted dice
esto apenas comienza y aún así se suma
otro capítulo o otra capa que es todavía
más compleja y son los audios de
Benedetti que reveló la revista semana
que es una revista nacional Alfredo Le
quiero preguntar Usted qué opina de
estos audios en los que Benedetti afirma
que recolectó 15.000 millones de pesos
cerca de 3,5 millones de dólares para la
campaña y que si él llegase a decir
quién financió al presidente Gustavo
Petro se irían todos a la cárcel y
además hay una tentativa de
investigación en la comisión en el
Consejo Nacional electoral precisamente
para identificar estos posibles vacíos
en la financiación
Pues mira yo lo que creo Es que
Benedetti se está autoincriminando y por
eso el presidente Petro inmediatamente
al tener claro de que no tiene ningún
tipo de duda sobre la financiación de
campaña entonces le dice que vaya a
donde su principal opositor político el
fiscal para que rinda las declaraciones
que tenga que rendir porque Benedetti en
un momento dice que lo están
deslegitimando para que no le crean sus
declaraciones tres minutos después dice
que él estaba era bajo los efectos de la
droga y el alcohol después dice que lo
Disculpen al presidente Díaz Arabia dice
todo tipo de cosas Pero como dice una
cosa al otro momento dice otra es decir
usted señala no creer a las
declaraciones de Benedetti
no lo que yo creo Es que Benedetti tiene
que ir bajo gravedad de juramento a
donde el fiscal donde corresponde la
investigación para que no queden entre
ires y directes y en ese sentido lo que
yo sí creo Es que la fiscalía debe tener
una atención oportuna porque recuerde
que buena parte de estas tensiones que
hay con el fiscal se dan cuando el
presidente Petro le pide al fiscal que
le diga por qué él no protegió a más de
200 personas que le han dado una lista
de personas que iban a ser asesinadas
por el clan del Golfo y que después
varias de ellas al parecer han aparecido
asesinadas es decir la fiscalía no es es
muy negligente cuando hay que proteger a
la población los intereses de la nación
pero cuando hay que hostigar al gobierno
de Petro ahí sí es muy acelerado así que
nosotros pedimos que haya justicia que
haya investigación y que el fiscal no
deje instrumentalizar el puesto para
asumir un papel básicamente De oposición
política aquí quiero hacer un paréntesis
simplemente de Claridad y es para
explicarle a nuestros televidentes que
en Colombia El fiscal general de la
nación es decir el encargado del lente
investigador en Colombia se elige de una
terna que presenta el presidente y este
es elegido de esa terna el presidente
actual el perdón el fiscal actual
Francisco Barbosa fue elegido de una
terna que presentó el presidente de
derechista Iván Duque y su gran parte de
su mandato del mandato del fiscal ha
coincidido con el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro y ahora Gustavo Petro es quien
presentará la terna al fiscal Hernán le
votó a usted la pregunta Cómo
interpretar estos 15 mil millones de los
que habla Benedetti mire en caso de ser
cierto es el escándalo de la mayor
magnitud en la historia política de
Colombia por lo menos lo reciente yo
creo que no había un gobierno de
referencia por allá la mitad de los años
90 el gobierno samper el llamado proceso
8000 que hoy se le ha empezado a
denominar a esta circunstancia proceso
15.000 precisamente haciendo una
referencia segundo no es solamente lo de
Benedetti ya hay varios informes de
portales de prensa serios donde las
cuentas de las campañas presidenciales o
de la campaña presidencial Petro no es
tan claras no se reportaron gastos Ahora
parece un nuevo elemento ellos no pueden
no deberían por lo menos emprender la
contra las instituciones en Colombia y
si insisto mucho Es que aquí había una
expectativa por un gobierno de cambio de
izquierda a la introducción del programa
se dijo el primer presidente
izquierdista en la historia de Colombia
en apenas nueve meses Está destruido en
popularidad lo dice la oposición están
las cifras verificables salió el
escándalo de la oposición fueron ellos
mismos hay apertura y se manda mensajes
de transparencia y de confianza todo lo
contrario es total incertidumbre
Entonces yo sí creo que esto hay que
mirarlo en amplio Y por supuesto que
cada uno de los detalles que ha ido
conociendo la opinión pública la opinión
internacional porque inclusive ya del
parlamento de los Estados Unidos ha
tocado el tema en las últimas horas por
supuesto que esto tendrá que
esclarecerse si no será un gobierno que
va a trazar todos estos caños que le
quedan simplemente en defenderse ataques
institucionales y muy mal le hace al
país por supuesto usted menciona el
proceso 8000 que como usted bien dice
ocurrió durante el gobierno de Ernesto
samper este proceso implicó en la
financiación de narcotraficantes a la
campaña presidencial de samper al menos
según las denuncias y de hecho Benedetti
en los audios que se filtró en la prensa
colombiana hace alusión a este proceso
8.000 diciendo que si no sabían Cómo
había comenzado el proceso 8000 era
porque una persona descontenta había
denunciado estas presuntas
irregularidades Alfredo le quiero dar la
pregunta a usted Hernán habla de un
golpe a las instituciones por parte del
gobierno Pedro y que en nueve meses este
gobierno ya diez meses este gobierno
está destruido Usted qué opina
Bueno ese es el querer digamos de la
oposición que tiene todo el poder
económico mediático incluso político es
decir eso es una oposición que tiene una
capacidad de incidencia a través de
décadas en el cual han estado en la en
la actividad política y que digamos que
hoy pretenden mostrarse como una especie
de renovación como si no hicieran parte
de una tradición política esta tradición
política incluso usted lo acaba de decir
es que el fiscal actual es el fiscal de
Duque es el fiscal de la oposición Es
que la procuradora fue funcionaria de
Duque es que todos estos poderes que
ellos han sostenido están totalmente
vinculados articulados para tratar de
impedir de que funcione y avance el
primer gobierno democrático en el país
por lo tanto Nosotros sabemos que van a
tener todas estas digamos intenciones de
magnificar los los sucesos pero es que
ellos se les olvida a todos los casos de
corrupción que han tenido sus dirigentes
Oscar Iván zuluaga vinculado con los
actos de corrupción multimillonarios con
odebrecht se les olvida todos los
procesos de de que tiene por ejemplo
fico que hoy se adelanta en una especie
de competencia entre la misma derecha
para ver quién es el primero que le pone
la denuncia ante la comisión de
acusación al presidente Petro pero fico
hay muchos sectores que lo acusan de
tener vínculos con el narcotráfico en
los sectores de de donde él es residente
es decir no lo digo yo son muchos si
usted se mete en redes sociales
encontrar aquí hay muchas denuncias
contra fico entonces pareciera recuerden
ustedes que la oposición viene de tener
embajador viene viene de tener un
embajador que en su Finca en Colombia
tenía cultivos de de de de de de drogas
cultivos ilícitos es decir Esos son los
que hoy nos quieren mostrar a nosotros
incoherentes Esos son los que hoy nos
quieren dar ejemplos como de decencia
pero lo concreto que hay que decir es
aquí no estamos haciendo como la época
de Álvaro Uribe Vélez y otros que era
tapen tapen aquí le estamos diciendo y
el presidente Petro ha dicho yo no me
voy a dejar chantajear de aquellos que
creen que por participar en una campaña
se le va a atrasar por puestos o
aquellos que creen que yo vine aquí a
hacerlas más prácticas sino que
inmediatamente hay que las instituciones
si Petro estuviera desconociendo las
instituciones o la estuviera poniendo en
riesgo no le estaría diciendo que fuera
donde su principal oposición queda el
fiscal en donde se tiene que la
investigación por eso creo que Petro lo
que está garantizando es la
institucionalidad para buscar la verdad
Alfredo usted Menciona un punto muy
importante y es Petro Bajo su discurso
de no negociar puestos él mismo disolvió
la coalición de gobierno en la que
estaba compartidos tradicionales como
los liberales y los conservadores Esto
ocurrió en abril y ocurrió precisamente
porque los partidos no estaban
dispuestos a apoyar una de sus tres
reformas cumbre en ese caso la reforma a
la salud y ahora luego de todos estos
escándalos el congreso congeló las
discusiones de las reformas a la salud a
la pensión y al trabajo o la reforma del
trabajo Perdón En ese sentido Qué puede
pasar en el congreso con el gobierno de
Petro se está quedando solo o puede
salir Avante de esta reformas
mira lo que hemos dicho es que el
gobierno en el gobierno en términos de
coalición recuerda que en la coalición
estaban partidos que habían perdido las
elecciones con Petro porque ellos se
fueron con el candidato del uribismo de
fico ya cuando Petro les gana ya hay una
composición lo interrumpo un solo
segundo Ya que ustedes menciona
reiteradamente a fico simplemente una
Claridad fico hace alusión a Federico
Gutiérrez que es el posible candidato
que escuchábamos al principio del debate
Ahora sí continúe Disculpe interrumpirlo
bueno Muchas gracias Sí pico es un
dirigente digamos del centro democrático
y del uribismo que tiene todo tipo de
escándalos y que hoy pues como está en
una campaña electoral aprovecha
cualquier situación para tratar de
seguir alimentando su campaña pero
también hay que decir que en este
escenario digamos de las reformas lo que
se ha planteado si vamos a tener una
coalición de gobierno es para hacer
reformas no es para una distribución
personalista o individual de las
estructuras de gobierno si se va a
participar del gobierno es para sacar
adelante un el gobierno y el programa de
gobierno que ganó en las urnas es para
hacer reformas una de esas reformas Es
que la salud en Colombia ha estado
manejada durante 30 años por unos
privados que ni fueron pulcros en el
manejo de los recursos hace pocos días
encontraron en una eps los privados que
manejan los recursos públicos de la
salud encontraron fajos de billetes en
los techos Pero además tienen deudas
impresionantes con los prestadores es
decir con las personas que atienden a la
población en salud entonces han sido
ineficientes y han sido corruptos y en
ese sentido lo que ha dicho el
presidente Petro es que si vamos a hacer
reformas es para hacer transformaciones
reales No simplemente para favorecer
voracidades burocráticas es la médula es
lo que está planteando por lo tanto lo
que está planteando es que el congreso
de la República tiene que definir en
este momento sí traiciona el pueblo
colombiano eh postergando la reformas
sacándole el bulto como dicen es decir
evadiendo a la responsabilidad de hacer
reformas para tener el derecho
fundamental a la salud o si va a seguir
dejando que privados sigan
enriqueciéndose con dineros públicos a
pesar de que hay millones de colombianos
que no tienen satisfacción en la
atención en salud es decir en Colombia
Estamos a una disyuntiva o avanzamos por
ejemplo y con esto termino Álvaro Uribe
Vélez el jefe de la oposición hoy Álvaro
Uribe Vélez destrozó las garantías
laborales de los jóvenes y de los
trabajadores y trabajar en general qué
es lo que estamos pidiendo básicamente
resolvamos el daño tan grave que le hizo
Álvaro Uribe Vélez a los colombianos que
los dejó en la miseria jamás jamás
generó empleo con quitándole el las
garantías laborales de los trabajadores
y eso les parece que es muy radical yo
creo que eso es básico lo que estamos
planteando derecho a la salud y garantía
laborales Germán Alfredo hace dos puntos
la primera vez que si el congreso no
sigue adelante con estas tres reformas
sería una traición al pueblo colombiano
y lo segundo que dice es que el
expresidente Álvaro Uribe le hizo un
daño al país a través por ejemplo
los cambios laborales que él implementó
Álvaro Uribe el expresidente es
precisamente el jefe y casi que fundador
de su partido centro democrático que le
responde bueno en este orden lo primero
que quiero señalar es que esa actitud de
desafío a las instituciones es la que
permanece por ejemplo en las relaciones
internacionales cuando el presidente
llama fuerza nace a la policía del Perú
o cuando en los recientes resultados
electorales de España dijo que era un
día de
1936 rememora rememorando el ascenso del
partido nazi en Alemania Así es que se
comportan ellos digamos no tiene la
capacidad de concertación de
conversación sino que es al ataque
cualquier otra discusión tienes que
saber que siempre van a terminar en el
nombre Uribe y Tengo que verme obligado
a responder sobre eso simplemente las
cifras discurso del representante
Mondragón versus las cifras el inicio
del presidente Uribe en el año 2012 el
desempleo estaba en el 19%, lo entregan
el 11 había una inversión extra mil
millones de dólares la entrega en 13 mil
millones de dólares Todo eso viéndose
reflejado Por supuesto en materia de
inversión y efectivamente en empleo
entonces aquí lo voy a interrumpir
Porque si nos vamos a debatir el
gobierno de Uribe claramente
Entonces yo me veo obligado a poder
responder porque no pueden decir que
todo fue muy mal y tengo que responder
la orquesta ha sido el discurso que han
utilizado Claro pero quiero regresar la
conversación al congreso y las reformas
actuales de Petro que cree usted es que
el congreso a ver el gobierno Petro
Petro hizo su carrera política en el
congreso y ahora le va a venir a decir
al congreso que si no aprueban lo que él
quiere conforme tal como lo es o cómo lo
mira Entonces es una traición pues donde
está la capacidad de la autonomía
legislativa donde está la crítica de los
partidos los mismos partidos que ellos
señalaban de ese régimen de el
establecimiento corrupto hoy son los que
les hacen las mayorías son los mismos y
no es cierto hoy ha quedado demostrado
aquí en Colombia en los medios de
comunicación como se evidenció la
entrega puestos burocracia cargos
públicos seguramente a cambio de tener a
esos partidos en torno al gobierno Acaso
no era eso lo que criticaban ese no era
el modelo de cambio que le decían al
país que no iba a seguir existiendo Pues
sigue existiendo pero quiero decir el
congreso de la República así sea una
relación política también tiene
autonomía y también pueden disponer
rechazar adherir o frenar y no por eso
nos podemos remitir a que son unos
traidores lo interrumpo porque ya se nos
acaba el tiempo y antes de llegar a
nuestra conclusión le quiero dar la
contrapregunta Alfredo Alfredo que
responder a si realmente era el gobierno
del cambio y en Colombia el gobierno
Petro ha hecho alianzas compartidos
tradicionales y vemos escándalos como de
los que hemos hablado
Mira si Petro estuviera buscando una
coalición con partidos tradicionales
para seguir quitándole los derechos
laborales a los jóvenes a los padres y a
las madres de los jóvenes para seguir
entregándole los recursos públicos de la
salud unos negociantes privados que han
desangrado el estado durante 30 años si
estuviera Petro básicamente para seguir
despojando las tierras a los campesinos
y seguir atrasando nuestro país en
materia agrícola en materia Industrial
seguramente recibiría el aplauso Y si
sería muy benévolo Petro pero como Petro
Está tratando un precio de
industrialización reacralización
formalización en materia laboral
recuperación de derechos laborales en tu
eje así se vuelve un monstruo Y ahí sí
le parece que es terrible que estos
sectores tradicionales se sumen a esa
lógica yo lo que les digo es que Y
finalizando en este sentido es que en
Colombia la gran problema y el gran
problema político es que Petro en unos
próximos meses tiene que suceder al
fiscal actual y el fiscal actual no
olviden Buenos días pidió que
precluyeran investigaciones contra
Álvaro Uribe Vélez y que fue negado y
Álvaro Uribe Vélez tiene más de treinta
procesos en investigación por lo tanto
está la verdadera preocupación del poder
político en Colombia tratar de que Petro
no cambie un fiscal y que lo ponga de
adorno para que siga la impunidad a
Álvaro Uribe y a todos los que han
tenido al parecer vínculos con masacres
con
falsos positivos con toda una
criminalidad Yo creo que esa es la
preocupación real y sabemos que vamos a
tener Pues que soportar muchos
obstáculos en 30 segundos la precisión
el próximo fiscal no lo elige el
presidente de la república el Presenta
una terna pero quien lo selecciona la
Corte Suprema de Justicia y por ahí hay
que empezar a partir del respeto también
a la división de poderes en Colombia hoy
amenazado lo dice la oposición no las
mismas cortes han emitido comunicados
pidiendo respeto al gobierno por esas
afectaciones como lo mencionaba al
inicio
el presidente Pedro podría enfrentar una
investigación en la comisión de
acusaciones de la cámara de
representantes cámara en la que ustedes
dos están representante cadavid que él
Espera a Petro y a su gobierno seguirá
en el mandato no seguirá acabará sus
cuatro años que piensa usted Pues en las
formas en Cómo va políticamente no sé si
logre sostenerse en materia de comisión
de acusaciones Pues tendrá que entrar a
conocerse el proceso que designen al
representante instructor investigador y
que el procedimiento como es jurídico
tiene que seguirse con toda la línea
argumental y probatoria aquí no es bajo
la visión política de si me gusta o no
eso es un tema distinto pero si es
responsabilidad penal Pues ojalá la
comisión que tiene las mayorías hoy el
gobierno nacional hoy las tiene es más
aquí hay que decirlo en esos términos el
país podrá los medios de comunicación
así lo dispone la ley en Colombia que
los procesos sobre el presidente de la
república son de carácter público no
reservado es decir que la comunidad
internacional los medios la opinión
podrá observar cada movimiento de lo que
allí sucede eso es muy importante en
virtud de transparencia aunque también
una Claridad Y es que desde que existe
esta comisión nunca un presidente ha
sido juzgado en contra en la historia de
este organismo Alfredo muy brevemente
Usted qué opina que puede pasar con el
gobierno Petro terminará no terminará
bueno los sectores de poder tradicional
van a querer poner todos los obstáculos
para que el gobierno de Petro pueda
desarrollar su programa de gobierno eso
estaba Claro pero aquí le corresponderá
al pueblo colombiano decidir si prefiere
malo conocido o bueno por conocer y si
prefiere quedarse en la lógica de esos
poderes tradicionales que ha amañado el
poder político el poder mediático el
poder digamos político para los
intereses de unas cuantas élites o logra
respaldar entender todas las tramas que
se van a construir en contra del
gobierno para impedir de que él adelante
y materialice la reformas sociales pero
que además nos de las garantías de que
avanza un proceso institucional para que
por fin haya un ente acusador o una ente
investigador como en el caso de la
fiscalía que no esté atravesado para
garantizarle impunidad en favor de los
sectores poderosos Yo creo que es el
debate central que tiene el país Si
queremos verdad si queremos reformas
sociales Si queremos superar la deuda
social Si queremos democracia en
Colombia dependerá del pueblo colombiano
de que acompaña al pueblo a al
presidente Pedro y a su gobierno en
estas procesos de reformas sociales y de
transformación institucionales Ahora les
voy a pedir algo prácticamente imposible
en 30 segundos la conclusión de los
escándalos de los que hemos hablado
Comenzando por usted Bernal No yo lo
puedo resumir en una palabra
incertidumbre y fracaso país esperaba
mucho más ha destruido la confianza a
las personas que lo eligieron ha
confirmado los temores de los que no lo
hicimos y los números las cifras y los
hechos hablan por sí solos hoy la
institucionalidad frenada hoy el
congreso paralizado hoy el país en total
incertidumbre la economía paralizándose
la inversión recibiendo mensajes
negativos incertidumbre es la palabra
Alfredo su conclusión muy
bueno el presidente Petro no se
arrodilla ante el chantaje no Resuelve
los problemas del país sobre la base del
amiguismo está dispuesto a buscar verdad
que no haya más impunidad en Colombia el
presidente está convencido de que
responder con las reformas sociales al
país el presidente sabe que hay
poderosos que van a impedir de que
avance una propuesta progresista en
Colombia pero el pueblo colombiano y el
presidente tendrán que tomar la decisión
de juntos avanzar en una nueva Colombia
Hernán cadavid representante a la cámara
de Colombia por el partido de oposición
centro democrático y Alfredo Mondragón
representante de el partido oficialista
pacto histórico Gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros y a ustedes Les agradecemos
nuestra la sintonía de France 24 la
producción del debate estuvo a cargo de
Luis Fernando Montes y la de los
invitados con Tania Herrera Los invito a
que sigan conectados con nosotros Porque
en minutos regresamos con más
información internacional
[Música]